en fait tsipras ce n'est pas une
révolution mais ça indique une évolution
et on voit bien que c'est pas le seul
signe la nouvelle politique de la banque
centrale européenne ait annoncé la
semaine dernière qu'elle allait racheter
sur le second marché
la commission européenne qui annonce la
flexibilité budgétaire pour les états la
victoire de sipera ce en grèce montre
qu'aujourd'hui faut réorienter les
politiques de l'union européenne
pourquoi parce que celle qu'on a mise en
place ensemble et c'est pas plus les
allemands les autres ne fonctionne pas
mais j'aimerais juste ajouter une chose
moi je comprends les allemands quand ils
disent il ya des choses qui ont été
signés il faut il faut les respecter
c'est logique on ne peut pas en vouloir
aujourd'hui l'allemagne de dire ça mais
il faut que l'allemagne comprennent que
ce qui a été signé et idiot et je prends
l'exemple de la grèce il jamais cette
cette dette ne sera intégralement
remboursé